Cô Can Yễm chỉ côn đune gia tại sinh cơ phỏ đang có suướng ra tăng đáng kể,
đặt ra thách thức mới đối với hệ thống Li tế và cơm thác không dịch.
Cơ quan của Li mệnh chuyển nhiễm sinh cơ phỏ cho miếng,
tụi đau năm đến ngày 12 tháng tảm, đã có mười bài trường hợp được kinh nhận,
cao gấp hơn hai lần cùng kỳ nát hành hình không trong 20 tư,
và vừa tổng số cao của cả năm trước.
Phần lớp bệnh nhân tựng đi đến các vùng đáng có dịch,
mang theo virus kỳ chở về, kết thờ với môi trường thuật lợi chương môi à ADS,
con gây từ vòng cao nhiều số suướng hết, nhưng bệnh có thể kiến người nhễm suy nhiều cáo sai,
anh gửi lĩnh nơi sống vào hòa đồng kinh tế.
Điều đời hỏi sinh cơ phỏ, duy trì, các bạn phòng trổ mỗi,
tăng cường kiểm soát đi tế tại cửa khẩu,
và nâng cao cạnh báo cộng đồng.
Vì phát hiện sớm và phản nướng kịch thời,
sẽ đáng vai cho thành chốt chúng bịn ám chẳng của các bạn vượt tâm kiểm soát.